confusion matrix with
machine learning what's in it for you
intro to machine learning need for
confusion matrixes
what is confusion matrix creating a
confusion matrix
confusion matrix metrics comparing
confusion matrixes
three by three confusion matrix
what is machine learning uh
so we're going to jump into machine
learning first because you have to have
that overview
a confusion matrix is about
understanding the results of your
machine learning
and validating it machine learning is a
subset of artificial intelligence
that trains machines with vast volumes
of data to think and act like humans
without being explicitly programmed so
here you see here we have a vast
volumes of data they come in you have a
trains the model
so we have our model kind of like a
black box and then it performs some
human-like task
in today's machine learning that's
usually has to do with a lot of
prediction of what the future is
or predict the best option to go forward
on
so in the type of machine learning
there are three major categories and so
we have our supervised
learning unsupervised learning
reinforcement learning and we talk about
uh supervised learning think about it
you already know the answer
uh so this is you have a huge amount of
data
you already know what you want out of it
and so we're going to train
the model to find that data
unsupervised learning means we're just
looking for stuff that matches
we don't know what goes together we
don't know what's going to fit together
so it doesn't really have an answer it
just says hey some of these things fit
together
let's see if we can find them and then
reinforcement learning is you don't know
the answer until it happens
so you can think of this as you do
something and you get
a reward um and so there's a reinforced
learning is like the cutting edge right
now so there's a lot of
work being done in that as in all of
these but that would really be the one
that is still
they're trying to figure out and when we
talk about supervised learning
we have regression and when you see the
word regression
think numbers usually float values
and classification classification is
true false yes no
this is a dog that is a cat when you're
doing
pictures and things like that and then
when you have unsupervised learning
uh there's clustering some of these
things fit together
and we cluster colors together can we
cluster them by both location and color
in an image it might be you are
clustering different measurements that
kind of fit together somehow
and then dimensionality reduction so
this is the more
simplified we can make it the better
so each classification is based on
removing
the chaos as it is in the thing and
bringing more
similarity to each area and then with
the reinforcement
learning there's what they call model
free
model free as you means you're not
actually training a model
this is kind of like you build a chart
this is what happened
this is what the this is what went into
it
sort of thing and then there's also
model building so you train the model as
it goes
so we're going to drill down to what is
classification i touched upon all those
different aspects that classification
is the yes no you're classifying it as
something
and the reason they spend a lot of time
on classification is because it's one of
the easier ones to understand
it's a little easier to track it's a
little easier to figure out the errors
on it
and when we're talking about a confusion
matrix we're usually talking about
classification
and i'll show you why here in a little
bit classification is a process of
classifying data into different
categories based on some of their common
characteristics
example a system classifying spam email
and you can see here we have our email
coming in some of them are spam some of
them are not
and the classifier has to only say yes
or no it's spam
or it's not spam
need for confusion matrixes
classification models have multiple
output categories most error measures
will tell
us the total error in our model but we
cannot use it to find out individual
instances
of errors in our models so you have your
input coming in you have your classifier
it measures the error and it says oh 53
of these are correct
but we don't know which 53 percent are
correct is it 53 percent correct
on guessing on the spam is it 23
guessing on spam and
27 percent guessing on what's not spam
this is where the confusion matrix comes
in
so during the classification we also
have to overcome the limitations of
accuracy
accuracy can be misleading for
classification problems
if there is a significant class
imbalance
a model might predict the majority class
for all cases
and have a high accuracy score
and so you can see here we have our
email coming in and there's two spams
the classifier comes in and goes hey it
only catches one of those spams and it
misclassifies one that's not spam
so our model predicted eight out of ten
instances and will have an accuracy of
eighty percent
but is it classifying correctly
a confusion matrix represents a table
layout of the different
outcomes of prediction and results of a
classification problem and helps
visualize its outcomes
and so you see here we have our simple
chart
predicted and actual the confusion
matrix
helps us identify the correct
predictions of a model for different
individual classes
as well as the errors so you'll see here
that the values predicted by our
classifier are along the rows
this is what we're going to guess it is
or our model is guessing what this is
based on its
training so we've already trained the
model to
guess whether it's spam or not spam or
whatever it is you're working on
and then the actual values of our data
set are along the columns
so this is the actual value it's
supposed to be
people who can speak english will be
classified as positives
so because they have a remember 001. do
you speak english yes no
and you could extend this that they
might have do you speak
french do you speak whatever languages
and so you might have a whole lot of
classifiers that you would look at each
one of these
people who cannot speak english will be
classified as negatives
so there'll be a zero so zero ones
the number of times our actual positive
values are equal to predicted
positive values gives us true positive
tp
the number of times our actual negative
values are equal to predictive negative
values gives us true negative tn
the number of times our model wrongly
predicts negative values as positives
gives us a false positive
fp and you'll see when you're working
with these a lot
you know memorizing that is false
positive you can easily figure out what
that is and pretty soon you're just
looking at the fp
or the tp depending on what you're
working on and the number of
times our model wrongly predicts
positive values as negatives
gives us a false negative fp
now i'm going to do a quick step out
here
let's say you're working in the medical
and we're talking about
cancer do you really want
a bunch of false negatives you want 0
under false negative
so when we look at this confusion matrix
if you have
five percent false positives and five
percent false negatives it'd be much
better to even have
twenty percent false positives because
they go in and test it and
zero false negatives the same might be
true
if you're working on say a car
driving is this a safe place for the car
to go
well you really don't want any false
positives
you know yes this is safe right over the
cliff
so again when you're working on the
project or whatever it is you're working
on
this chart suddenly has huge value
we were talking about spam email how
many
important emails say from your banking
overdraft charge coming
in that you want to be a a true
a false negative you don't want it to go
in the spam folder
likewise you want to get as much of the
spam out of there but you don't want to
miss anything really important
confusion matrix metrics are performance
measures which help us find the accuracy
of our classifier
there are four main metrics accuracy
precision recall and f1 score
the f1 score is the one i usually hear
the most and accuracy
is usually what you put on your chart
when you're standing in front of the
shareholders how accurate is it people
understand
accuracy f1 score is a little bit more
on the math side and so you got to be a
little careful when you're quoting f1
scores in the
when you're sitting there with all the
shareholders because a lot of them will
just glaze over
so confusion matrix metrics are
performance measures
which help us find the accuracy of our
classifier there are four main metrics
accuracy the accuracy is used to find
the portion of the correctly classified
values
it tells us how often our classifier is
right
it is the sum of all true values divided
by the total values
and this makes sense uh again it's one
of those things
i don't want to for you know what
depends on what you're looking for
are you looking for not to miss any spam
mails
are you looking to drive down the road
and not run anybody over
precision is used to calculate the
model's ability to classify
positive values correctly it answers the
question
when the model predicts a positive value
how often is it right
it is the true positive divided by the
total number of predicted positive
values again this one uh depends on what
project you're working on
whether this is what you're going to be
focusing on
so recall it is used to calculate the
model's ability to predict positive
values
how often does the model actually
predict the correct
positive values it is the true positives
divided by the total number of
actual positive values and then your f1
score
it is the harmonic mean of recall and
precision it is useful when you need to
take both precision and recall
into account consider the following two
confusion matrix
derived from two different classifier to
figure out which one performs better
we can find the confusion matrix for
both of them
and you can see we're back to does it
classify
whether they can speak english or or
non-speaker they speak some they don't
know the english language and so we put
these two uh
confusion matrixes out here we can go
ahead and do the math behind that we can
look up the accuracy that's a tpn plus
tn
over the tf plus tn plus fp plus
fn and so we get an accuracy of 0.8125
and we have a precision if you do the
precision which is your
tp truth positive over tp plus
fp we get 0.891
and if we do the recall we'll end up
with the 0.825 that's your tp over tp
plus
fn and then of course your f1 score
which is two times precision times
recall
over precision plus recall and we get
the 0.857
and if we do that with another model
let's say we had two different models
and we're trying to see which one we
want to use
for whatever reason we might go ahead
and compute the same things we have our
accuracy
our precision and our recall and our f1
score
and as we're looking at this we might
look at the accuracy
because that's really what we're
interested in is how many people
are we able to classify as being able to
speak
english i really don't want to know if
i'm you know i i really don't want to
know if
they're non-speakers i'd rather miss 10
people speaking english
instead of 15. and so you can see from
these charts we'd probably go with the
first model
because it does a better job guessing
who speaks english and has a higher
accuracy because in this case
that is what we're looking for so uh
with that we'll go ahead and pull up a
demo so you can see what this looks like
in the
python setup in in the actual coding
for this we'll go into anaconda
navigator
if you're not familiar with anaconda
it's a really
good tool to use as far as doing display
in demos and for quick development
as a data scientist i just love the
package
now if you're going to do something
heavier lifting there's some limitations
with anaconda and with the setup
but in general you can do just about
anything in here with your python
and for this we'll go with jupiter
notebook jupiter lab is the same as
jupyter notebook you'll see they now
have integration with
pi charm if you work in pi charm
certainly there's a lot of other
integrations that
anaconda has and we've opened up
i simply learned files i work on and
create a new file
called confusion matrix demo and the
first thing we want to note is the
data we're working with uh here i've
opened it up in
a wordpad or notepad or whatever
you can see it's got a row of headers
comma separated and then all the data
going down below
and then i save this in the same file so
i don't have to remember what path i'm
working on
of course if you have your data
separated and you're working with a lot
of data you probably want to put it into
a different folder or file depending on
what you're doing
and the first thing we're going to do is
go ahead and import our tools
we're going to use the pandas that's our
data frame
if you haven't had a chance to work with
the data frame please review pandas data
frame
going to simply learn you can pull up
the pandas data frame
tutorial on there and then we're going
to use uh
the scikit framework which is all
denoted as
sklearn and i can just pull this in you
can see here's the
scikit learn.org with the stable version
that you can import into your python
and from here we're going to use the
train test split
splitting our data we're going to do
some pre-processing
we're going to do use the logistic
regression model
that's our actual machine learning model
we're using
and then what this quote this particular
setup is about is we're going to do the
accuracy score
the confusion matrix and the classifier
report
so let me go ahead and run that and
bring all that information in
and just like we open the file we need
to go ahead and load our data in here
so we're going to go ahead and do our
pandas read csv
and then just because we're in jupyter
notebook we can just put data to read
the data in here
a lot of times we'll actually let me
just do this i prefer to do the
just the head of the date or the top
part and you can see we have
age sex i'm not sure what cp stands for
test bps cholesterol so a lot of
different
measurements if you were in this domain
you want to know what all these
different
measurements mean i don't want to focus
on that
too much because when we're talking
about data science a lot of times you
have no idea what the data means
if you've ever looked up the breast
cancer measurement it's just a bunch of
measurements and numbers
unless you're a doctor you have no idea
what those measurements mean
but if it's your specialty and your
domain you better know them so we're
going to go ahead and create y
and it's going to we're going gonna set
it equal to the target uh so here's our
target value here
and there's either one or zero
so we have a classifier if you're
dealing with one zero true false
what do you have you have a classifier
and then our x is going to be
everything except for the target
so we're going to go ahead and drop the
target axis equals
1. remember that's columns versus the
index
or rows axis equals 0 would would
give you an error but you would drop
like row 2.
and then we'll go ahead and just print
that out so you can see what we're
looking at
and here we have y data x data
and you can see from the x data we have
the x head and we can go ahead and just
do print
the y head data and run that
so this is all loading the data that
we've done so far
if there's a confusion in there go back
and rewind the tape and review it
and then we need to go ahead and split
our data into our
x train x test y train
y test and then keep in mind you always
want to split the data
before we do the scalar and the reason
is is that
you want the scalar on the training data
to be set on the training data
data or fit to it but not on the test
data think of this as being out in the
field
you're not it could actually alter your
results
so it's always important to do make sure
whatever you do to the training data
or whatever fit you're doing is always
done on the training
not on the test and then we want to go
ahead and
scale the data now we are working with
a linear regression model i'll mention
this here in a minute when we get to the
actual model
so some sometimes you don't need to
scale it when you're working with linear
regression models it's not going to
change your result as much as say a
neural network where it has a huge
impact but we're going to go ahead and
take here's our x train
x test y train y test we create our
scalar
we go ahead and scale the scale is going
to fit the
x train and then we're going to go ahead
and take our x train and transform it
and then we also need to take our x test
and transform it based on the scale on
here so that our x is now
between that nice minus one to one and
so this is all
uh our pre-data setup
and hopefully all of that looks fairly
familiar to you if you've done a number
of our other classes and you're up to
the setup on here and then we want to go
ahead and do is create our model and
we're going to use the
logistic regression model and from the
logistic regression model
we're going to go ahead and fit our x
train and y train and then we'll run our
predicted value on here
and let's go ahead and run that and so
now
we are we actually have like our x test
and our prediction so if you remember
from
our matrix we're looking for the actual
versus the prediction
and how those compare and
if i take us back up here you're going
to notice that we imported the accuracy
score
the confusion matrix and the
classification report
and there's of course our logistic
regression the model we're using for
this
and i did mention is going to talk a
little bit about scalar and the
regression model
the scalar on a lot of your regression
models your basic mass
standard regression models and i'd have
to look it up for the logistic
regression model
when you're using a standard regression
model you don't need to scale the data
it's already just built in by the way
the model works
in most cases but if you're in a neural
network and
there's a lot of other different setups
then you really want to take this
and fit that on there and so
we can go in and do the accuracy and
this is if you remember correctly we
were looking at the accuracy
with the english speaking so this is
saying our accuracy
as to whether this person is i believe
this is the heart
data set
it's going to be accurate about 85
percent of the time
as far as whether it's going to predict
the person's going to have
a heart condition or the one as it comes
up with the zero one on there
which would mean at this point that you
have an 85 percent uh being correct on
telling someone they're extremely high
risk for a heart attack kind of thing
and so we want to go ahead and create
our confusion matrix
and we just do that
of course the software does everything
for us so we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see right here um here's our
25
prediction uh correct predictions right
here
and if you remember from our slide i'll
just bring this over so it's a nice
visual we have our true
positive false positive
uh so we had 25 which were true that it
said hey this person is going to be high
risk
at heart and we had four that were still
high risk that it said were false
so out of these 25 people or out of
these 29 people and that makes sense
because you have 0.85
out of 29 people it was correct on 25 of
them
and so uh here's our accuracy score we
were just looking at that
our accuracy is your true positive and
your true negative
over all of them so how true is it there
is our accuracy
coming up here 0.85 and then we have our
nice matrix generated from that
and you can see right here is a similar
matrix we had going for the from the
slide
and this starts to this should start
asking questions at this point
um so if you're in a board meeting or
you're working with this
you really want to start looking at this
data here and saying well
is this good enough is uh this number of
people
and hopefully you'd have a much larger
data set it might is my
confusion matrix showing for the true
positive and uh
false positive is that acceptable for
what we're doing
and of course if you're going to put
together whatever data you're putting
out you might want to separate the
true negative false positive false
negative true positive
and you can simply do that by doing the
confusion matrix
and then of course the ravel part lets
you set that up so you can just split
that right up into a nice tuple
and the final thing we want to show you
here in the
coding on this part is the confusion
matrix metrics and so
we can come in here and just use the
matrix equals classification report
the y test and the predict and then
we're going to take that classification
report
and go ahead and print that out and you
can see here it does a nice job
giving you your accuracy your micro
average
your weighted average you have your
precision
your recall your f1 score and your
support
all in one window so you can start
looking at this data and saying oh
okay our precision's at point eight
three
uh point eight seven for getting a a
positive and point eight three for the
negative side
for a zero and we start talking about
whether this is a valid
information or not to use and when we're
looking at a heart attack prediction
we're only looking at
one aspect what's the chances of this
person having a heart attack or not
you might have something where we went
back to the languages
maybe you also want to know whether they
speak english or
hindi or french and you can see right
here that we can now
take our confusion matrix and just
expand it as big as we need to depending
on how many different classifiers we're
working on
so thank you for joining us today for
more information please visit
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here